hi i'm nancy baim i'm a senior principal
researcher at microsoft research in new
england
and i'm here with jean burgess from
queensland university of technology and
we're going to
present some work from a book we've
recently published called twitter a
biography
one of the great things about microsoft
research in new england is that we have
a really generous
visitors program where we're able to
collaborate with faculty who come to us
from all around the world and spend some
time
and what we're showing you today is an
outgrowth of that work gene you want to
say a bit about who you are
yeah hi i'm i'm jean burgess i'm a
professor of digital media at qut
where i lead the digital media research
center and like nancy said
i was a real privilege to be part of the
microsoft research visiting researchers
program when back when
we started this project which we're
going to tell you all about today
all right so as you all know social
media matter
uh you can look at the headlines uh any
day and it's there
i pulled these from the internet just
the other day facebook worker quits and
discuss
youtubers draw a massless cloud twitter
adds context to trending topics so
all around us we see that social media
are making the news
even as even as they're really
trivialized they are a key component of
our personal life of our public life of
our political life
platforms have have a tremendous amount
of power
they they shape the
communication available to us they shape
what's able to happen
in different spaces i like this image
because it shows the original platform
of the stage
in this type case in a concert hall and
if you think about it you can look at
this picture and it's very obvious that
this is a space that's been physically
designed
and built by architects in order to
create particular kinds of social
relations particular kinds of
interactions particular categories of
people
and the same is true when we think about
social media platforms
on the one hand it seems like we all
know a platform when we see it right we
know facebook we know youtube tick tock
these things are all
uh visible we can look at them and say
oh yeah that's a social media platform
but at the same time
conceptually theoretically they're
really quite slippery for a number of
reasons one is that
they're constantly changing so if the
interface today
doesn't necessarily look like the
interface earlier so this raises
a lot of questions about how are we
going to theorize how are we going to
analyze how are we going to compare
these platforms
when they're continuously transforming
and we need to be able to do this if
we're going to understand it so
conveniently
enough gene and i have written a book on
this topic
twitter a biography so what we want to
do today is spend a little time with you
walking you through the basic model that
we've come up with in order to
create a ways to do these coherent
rigorous systematic analyses of
platforms that can allow us to compare
them to one another as well as to track
them over time and i'm going to hand it
over to gene for a bit now
yes thanks nancy so our our case study
obviously for
for this book this application of the
platform biography is
twitter uh but just to to remind us what
it looked like when it started
uh back in in the mid 2000s when
web 2 was the buzzword of the day and we
didn't like to include vowels in the
name of social media companies
that this is uh the one of the very
first
kind of uh company pieces of company
communication about this new service
that was formally launched in july 2006
a new mobile service that helps groups
of friends bounce random thoughts around
with
sms it was actually a side project
within the podcasting company
audio use short message service or sms
protocols to post what were called
status updates to the web for the
benefit of your friends and your
followers
so even within the company however it
was
you know really not certain what this
was really for was it for
sharing news or information with people
was it for just maintaining social
networks through what is commonly called
phatic communication so um even at the
beginning
there's a lot of uncertainty and
ambiguity around this this is what the
original home page looked like so you
can see that
the way that we're invited as users to
think about this new platform this new
service is
very kind of jokey very informal very um
interpersonal and social rather than uh
very serious important or newsy
and the the use of cool internet slang
like
what up is a pretty big feature as well
these are the
some of the early tweets from the the
founders and early employees of the
company
so um actually no real idea about what
it's
for just kind of joking around this is
actually pre the formal launch as well
so
this is one of the first employees
saying this thing sucks
now company ceo jack dorsey one word
status update
literally answering the question what
are you doing with
probably the only word that came to him
in that state
nancy and i like many people who studied
the internet
and or were just interested in social
media started our own accounts
in around the same time actually march
2007 when
the buzz had started to kind of
circulate around what was then called
the blogosphere
as you can see there from this
screenshot from
nancy's archive which uh
where these archives were made available
to users in in early 2013
so nancy is literally answering the
question that was posted all users what
are you doing
um very literally signing up for twitter
even though i don't think you'd want it
i want it and nancy doesn't tweet again
until much later 2000
in 2007 when with characteristic comic
timing i have to say
she says wondering why anyone is
following me when i never twitter
my first tweets are there's a lot more
of them
but similarly very mundane every day
taking literally the idea
that you simply share what you're up to
with your friends
today users are uh invited to
participate with the question what's
happening so going from a really me
centered
to a a world-centered kind of
idea about the platform and the
communication can that can happen on it
of course as we all know twitter is a
major
mediator of news events from natural
disasters and crises
to global pandemics and politics
it also remains a really vibrant
and active site for everyday popular
culture
so kpop twitter is a global force to be
reckoned with
it's grounded in fandom and pop culture
rather than big serious news and
politics actors and so this kind of
journey from totally mundane some would
say trivial and almost useless
technology at the fringes of a little
podcasting startup to this kind of
global news environment with all of the
social problems that are
very well known to be associated with it
we're really interested in kind of
understanding how did this how does this
actually happen how do you actually get
from there
to here and so this is where the
platform biography
approach telling this life story of the
platform comes in so i'm going to hand
back to you nancy
so what we're trying to do with this
approach the platform biography is not
just to tell a story of twitter
although it emerged through our efforts
to tell that story of twitter
what we're trying to do is to create a
model that can be used to analyze any
social media platform so what we're
arguing is that
when you look at this trajectory of
twitter and we'll talk a little bit more
about it that gene
well quite a bit more about it that gene
has just laid out
we're arguing that you need to think
about a number of different forces that
come into play with one another and
intersect and bounce off one another and
and uh sometimes antagonize one another
so one set of things is around the
technology and the design
and i think this is what people often
think of when they think about a
platform they think what do you see when
you go to the
site and you load it or when you open
the app so this would include the front
stage
things like the interface and the
features of it also the backstage things
the software the algorithms the apis
that allow
that platform to engage with other
platforms around the internet
and the ecosystems of devices and
services that come together
to make that platform work but there's
also the cultures of use that happen
through these sites the k-pops versus
the news people
there's the communicative and expressive
content of what people are sharing the
tweets themselves or the facebook
updates or the instagram photos or
pick your platform whatever kinds of
content people are sharing there
there's the practices and the
understandings of the users themselves
and there's also a lot of public
discourse about platforms so example
one thing that happened with twitter uh
there was a moment
some years ago where a study was done
that revealed that most tweets were
quote
pointless babble and this got circulated
all over the news and was very integral
to twitter's effort to sort of
rehabilitate themselves as a serious
site not pointless babble
so public discourse is really really
influential and then of course the
business models have to be taken into
account what are the incentives that
these companies have
and what do they think they're doing
when they make the kinds of changes that
they do
we demonstrate this approach in the book
by collecting a variety of materials and
one could think about collecting a
similar sort of materials for any kind
of platform so
there's a lot of secondary literature
about twitter there's books about
twitter there's
uh articles there's all of that kind of
things
we did this oral history trace scroll
back sort of interviews with archives as
prompts so gene mentioned that
twitter made it possible to download
your archive and one consequence of gdpr
is that
most platforms will now you make your
archive available to you if you request
it
so we asked people to go back through
their archives prior to being
interviewed and marked places where they
thought that their
the way that they tweeted had changed
and so then when they came into the lab
with us we
sat down and we projected their timeline
their archive on a big screen and they
just walked us through the points where
they felt it had changed and
we talked about what what had happened
there we combined this with
the wayback machine which allowed us to
look at what did twitter actually look
like
at that time we looked at media
and tech press coverage there were a lot
of user blogs one of the funny things
about social media is that
people really like to talk about their
experience and they really like to write
how to's and they like to explain to
people exactly what they're doing wrong
and how they should stop doing that
thing that was actually a piece of what
sparked this whole project was our
interest in the ways that users were
continuously telling each other they
were using twitter wrong
and then twitter itself like many social
media platforms also blogs its own
experience and so there are corporate
materials which are
up now and that also are available
through archives like the wayback
machine so we drew on all of these
things together to try to speak to all
of those areas
that i just outlined before
i one thing that became clear
as we did this was that
in any qualitative project you end up
within a huge array of materials
and you want to be able to to shape it
somehow to focus it somehow and i should
say that the
biography the concept of biography was
appealing in large part because
just as with a human when you write a
biography of that person
you're never going to be in their brain
just like you're never going to be in
the epicenter of whatever the real
twitter
is fully understanding its inner
workings so it's always going to have
in inadequate access and it's also
always only only going to be partial so
the challenge is
how do you how do you tell as much as
you can how do you get to the core of
that story how do you find
a way in that really gives you a window
into the big picture that's told through
all of these materials
yet allows you to focus it which is
always a challenge in qualitative
research but in a
in a scheme like this very much very
much the case
and what we came up with by looking at
those reports of when people said their
behaviors had changed and looking at the
coverage and when flurries of
of coverage happened was that a really
key way to get at this was through
specific features that are at the heart
of the platform and that can really be
used to tell that story so
in our case we
focused on these three features the at
reply the hashtag
and the retweet which i think anybody
who with a passing familiarity of
twitter
has a hard time imagining twitter
without these features in fact
one response uh when we talk about this
is sometimes
wait a minute those weren't always there
uh it's
it's sort of shocking to people to
realize that the at reply was not built
from day one
but it wasn't and what we found with all
three
of these features is that they go they
went through
a life cycle during a a particularly
uh important moment in twitter's history
in the late audis from around 2006 to
2008 or so
where the users
recognized the ambiguity of the platform
saw that there were all kinds of things
they wanted to be able to do that they
didn't know how to do with the platform
uh or that it was just tricky to do
because it was so it was just an empty
box right that was all there was and you
were very limited in how many characters
so they encountered these different
kinds of problems
uh like how do you say who you're
talking to how do you say what you're
talking about how do you say that
somebody else said this already
and they they they and by they i mean
the users the people using
twitter uh said oh we have a problem
here
uh let's fix it and they did that by
appropriating
these tools like the at reply which had
been used of course in email but
in in other modes also and brought them
in
uh twitter sees this happening and it
incorporates
those features into their actual
infrastructure
there's contestation about the way
they've been incorporated about how
they're used
and there's a continuous iteration and
in fact all three of these features
are still undergoing contestation and
iteration
throughout this process of contestation
iteration appropriation what we see and
gene has alluded to this already
is this emerging tension between is
twitter a place for
serious news where you need to be to
find out what's happening in the world
which is how they now sort of position
themselves or is it a place for people
to have this more effective
ephemeral social connection where
they're
continuously attuned to one another and
what
we see happening over time is that the
former
bid for newsworthiness for being
important
becomes very important to the business
models
and to the public discourse in a way
that continuously puts
this use of it of being more sociable
hanging around joking going on
long tangents watching tv together those
kinds of things
become less desirable and seen as do
using twitter
wrong or at least a somewhat subversive
alternative
use of twitter next
what we see throughout all of this is
that when twitter incorporates each of
these things
into the platform when it says oh an at
reply is a good thing to have
ooh a retweet is a good thing to have
it does it in a way that allows it to be
counted so it creates metrics and each
tweet then starts coming packaged with
metrics how many times has it been
retweeted
how many replies has it gotten so you
can imagine what happens of course
right people start writing tweets in
order to get replies in order to get
retweeted and one of the things that we
would argue
is that people also start doing things
like creating bots so that they can up
those numbers they start
creating disinformation that has high
likelihood of becoming retweeted so you
have this
confluence of factors where a
technology shifts from something
uh that is very youthful and
free-floating and doesn't really know
what it wants to be
that runs on a social logic of hanging
out with friends and using cool internet
slang that shifts into a media industry
logic of presenting
packaged material with nice metrics that
can be sold to advertisers
uh so i'm going to turn it to gene now
to walk us through the three features
a little more detailed yeah i'm going to
take a a very rapid sort of
journey through those early years that
nancy was talking about
in each of these three features and
think a little bit about those phases of
early emergence and appropriation
embedding by the platform
and contestation and how they've
continued today so
the first of these the first to be
invented
or deliberately created i should say by
users is the at
so in the in the book the twitter a
biography book we we talk about
the as as the key to twitter's
sociability or perhaps a way of thinking
about it is
a way that the platform and its users
modulate
social connections for good and
increasingly
not so good
originally uh the very first uses of
that
uh at symbol which we're familiar with
from email addresses
was drawn from other platforms like
uh like dodgeball where the at is used
to mark a location or an activity so
this idea of twitter as being for a
status update rather than
for uh social conversation is
very much embedded in the uses of these
the the early
the three early twitter co-founders and
employees so
dom's literally at an errand
ev's having a breakfast burrito at a
place herbivore
and jack not using the symbol but
at the actual word is at work
as nancy was saying the the bloggers
in these early days were very active in
talking about twitter and how
how it all works how it should work and
there's some debate about who
used the at symbol to refer to another
user first but we think this might be
the first one
so at with a space because there's no
hardwired
connection between somebody's username
and a web link or anything like that at
the stage
at buzz you broke your thumb and you're
still twittering that's some serious
devotion
around the same time so this is the end
of 2006 a mere sort of five months after
twitter launches some users start
explicitly having conversations about
should we invent some way to kind of
really explicitly
signal to other users that you're
directing a comment at them or trying to
get their attention
and neil crosby
jokingly reminds ben darlow
that this would the at symbol would be a
good way to do this
fast forward just a few months uh to
january 2007 and the sort of tech
blogger eric meyer
is is uh in a very long post kind of
expressing his dissatisfaction with
how sociable and chatty and and mundane
twitter has become
is complaining about these kinds of
practices like using the app feature to
speak directly to other
users saying twitter's becoming the most
inefficient and unusable version of irc
internet relay chat ever look people if
you want to chat get a chat room you
know
at the very same time
and i think nancy and i would both place
ourselves in this camp
other people were were becoming
fascinated with the kinds of
ambient intimacy as uh lisa reichelt
called it
that social media was becoming
associated with so the ability to get to
know
other people either through directly
conversing with them
or just by letting the flow of their
everyday experience
kind of flow past you as you're on
social media so
this is a really active debate and it
directly centered
upon the use of the at reply i mentioned
feature where some people were really
angry
about being subjected to other people's
social chit chat
and other people were really valuing
that and
as the use of the app feature becomes
really
embedded in twitter the twitter
community
the twitter the company or the technical
platform has to figure out
what to do about this should they
hardwire it in so that we see everybody
else's replies
or should we somehow background it in
the interface so that we don't have to
see other people's social interactions
well fast forward again to the
introduction of
new twitter so called and
this blog post from the official twitter
blog
talks about how a change that they had
started to make
to background replies to people
you don't follow so if i reply to nancy
and you don't follow
nancy but you follow me you don't have
to see my conversation with nancy
this created a huge uproar in the kind
of early
user community and it speaks to this
tension in the business model between
trying to
promote social networking and trying to
create a
clean well-lit media business
environment
since then the at feature has come to be
used for far more and social
conversation and connection
so we now have the ability to reply to
yourself and for that to be
embedded in what's called a tweet thread
so for example
this person here has anthony has used
aggregated a whole lot of responses to
the question
things you wish your professor knew and
created almost like a mini essay
using the thread and of course
the reply function is also used for
trolling
harassment and kind of flame wars on
twitter
we look at patterns of different kinds
of tweeting
over time this is covering that
twitter's sort of early to middle age
period from
2006 through to about 2016.
we can see in the blue there are plain
tweets so tweets that don't mention
other users
purple retweets red replies
and green is mentioning other users so
saying at nancy in the middle of a tweet
right in the beginning of it
and we can see that twitter had a really
strong period of
kind of conversational growth between
about
2009 and 2012. and since then it's
actually become
less conversational much more i would
say broadcasty
you can see the growth of retweets which
we'll talk to in a moment
so uh i think the overall narrative or
the
the uh the life story of this character
in twitter's life
is that the the at reply or the ad
feature went from
being a tool for sort of sociable
chatter
to becoming um something that is used
for tweet storms and threads and and
and and pylons
the hashtag is the second of our
characters in
in twitter's biography so we think about
this one
as having originally been invented as a
way of kind of organizing or
coordinating
the twitter conversation that was the
need that users were seeking to
fill but of course hashtags have become
something quite different today
one thing to really acknowledge here is
that
despite the fact that nancy and i have
both been on twitter since near the
beginning
many of the existing historical
materials
are still existing because they're
written by people with a lot of access
to
an interest in uh tech blogging and
having their own websites and so on
so with that caveat it still does seem
that
the person who made the hashtag most
popular or visible
and promoted it most actively was chris
messina who's very happy to claim the
title of inventor of the hashtag
i think a number of users were trying to
find ways to do a similar thing which is
to
do something about the huge amount of
sheer amount of information
the sheer amount of material that was
flowing through your twitter feed
how could we organize ourselves a bit
better and if if we wanted to organize
ourselves do we want to organize
organize ourselves into into groups of
people
or to be want to organize the
conversation into channels or
topics and that's what this proposal for
the use of
the pound symbol uh or hash symbol as
it's called in the uk in australia
to organize topics or channels and in
this original post
uh messina goes into quite a lot of
depth and thinking about how
irc channels work for example how other
how other kind of social networking
platforms organize things
but the hashtag doesn't really take off
properly until it finds its use case and
early on that use case
was for coordinating real-time
information about acute events
like natural disasters and crises and in
this case
a bushfire or a brushfire in san diego
hashtags themselves started to
proliferate so users needed to invent
ways to
organize the hashtags and third-party
websites like hashtags.org were
developed this is about 2000 early 2008
in order to kind of aggregate the
hashtags that were
being used at that stage mainly for
events like like
crises or fast-moving news events but
also for conferences
mainly tech conferences and in fact
twitter really takes off
at south by southwest that same year
but hashtags are actually even used as
as kind of meeting places or
as organized events as in the case of
the
ag chat hashtag tags which have their
versions in australia in canada and
elsewhere where
early on they were used so the farmers
come in for the fields on a wednesday
night at 6 pm
jump on the ag chat or and talk about
life on the farm mental health issues
policy issues
and business practices and so on
of course hashtags are also used just as
kind of exclamations as jokes
and they're really really really
overused by social media marketers quite
a bit
as this as this um
meme kind of is getting at
but where i think hashtags have really
found their place
in kind of the popular imagination the
mainstream media
is as the coordinators of of issue
publics
and and social movements for example
there's
an organization a media organization in
australia called indigenous x
which was founded both simultaneously
both as a hashtag
a community around that hashtag and as a
media franchise
that seeks to amplify the voices of
first nations people
in australia and most famously
black lives matter
as as a hashtag started to gather
uh momentum on twitter in the wake of
trayvon martin's shooting by george
zimmerman
uh later became a social movement and
then actually an organization
by virtue of the hashtags use
in street protests and so on
similarly metoo actually was originally
originally the name of an organization
founded by tarana burke
but alyssa milano uh tweeted
that hashtag as an opportunity to
to share testimony for for
survivors of sexual violence and sexual
harassment to share testimony
and from there it becomes synonymous
with a seismic shift in the way that
sexual harassment is actually treated
number of high profile
court cases and so on
looking at the data again in in the
trends in tweets with
no hashtags and tweets with hashtags we
can see
uh they have kind of steadily grown and
become embedded
in in twitter but still a relatively
minority
practice so i think the story of the
hashtag
is from a way for users to organize
themselves and their conversations into
channels or groups
to the kind of formation of ad-hoc
publics
and in fact cultural war zones because
of course
those hashtags associated with social
movements attract
vitriol debate contestation as much as
they do support
finally the retweet originally developed
as a way
to to give credit to other users to
accurately
quote their words and to amplify
the voices of others
this was the clearest example in our in
our
in our materials of a lot of different
options being tried out
by users there was ht for hat tip so in
other words i heard this from nancy so
ht
nancy baim straight retweets
via spelling out the word retweet or
even retweeting
and later on the modified tweet so that
you could
repost something somebody else said but
with alterations
this is starts to emerge uh quite late
quite a bit later
in october 2008 you can see i wasn't too
keen on the recent and rapid
growth in retweeting about five seconds
later
i'm making jokes about retweeting by
embedding retweets within retweets
within retweets about
tweets from people who wanted more
retweets so we can already see
that there's a self-awareness here about
how retweeting is about attention and
attention logics and metrics as nancy
was talking about earlier
nancy's commenting on how the manual
retweeting practices meant that
tweets could change and um and and be
and morph and perhaps degraded meaning
as they were
spread around perhaps as people trying
to stay within the 140
character limit kept cutting off more
and more of your tweet to fit in the
retweet
at retweet at retweet chain so
uh as as biz stone says in this official
twitter blog post
he says uh that retweets were a great
example of twitter teaching us what it
wants to be
so that the company decides that
it's really important to embed the
retweet as an actual
hardwired feature of the platform
but of course in doing so they close off
some of those different
options and norms around retweeting
because the feature can only work one
way it has to work the same way for
everyone in every client
and this gives us the concept set sketch
on the this slide here
is the concept sketch for what became
known as the button
retweet so rather than typing retweet at
nancy baim
i just now hit a button not only do i
just hit a button
but even if you don't follow that follow
nancy and i retweet some
characteristically pithy and humorous
thing that nancy says
you're going to see nancy's profile
picture in your stream
and underneath that it might say
retweeted by
jean burgess so this seems like a minor
technical detail but it creates
an enormous amount of angst and
contestation
in the community because they want to
follow who they're following they don't
want
if someone someone you know perhaps
ahead of state that they don't want to
follow
uh is retweeted into their stream that
feels like
a lack of respect for the boundaries and
the twitter experience that they want
they have set up for themselves
perhaps most significantly though
retweets become part of
the metrics that twitter feeds even me
an ordinary user to tell me
which of my tweets are more successful
in gaining more attention
in being spread more so
and and these days you've got a
dashboard just like any other media
producer that tells you
the trends which of your which of your
content is
is gaining more engagement impressions
so it's treating me like
uh a little mini media producer so these
are this is the difference between the
kind of media logics
as nancy was saying and the social
objects that twitter really started with
and the most uh outstanding thing about
this
chart i think is the extent to which
retweets are growing and growing and
growing
um and plain tweets or just things i
might want to say to the world
are shrinking and shrinking and
shrinking and conversation is being
squeezed out
by broadcasting and retweeting
i would say so i think the story of the
retweeters
from a respectful nerdy citation
practice
to a metric and now just kind of a
compulsive amplifier button that we just
hit and hit and hit
in our use of twitter if we're not
really mindful
so that was a very rapid fly through of
the three features i'm going to hand
over to you nancy to
make sense of it all so i think if we
look across these
these three features uh with this
approach of drawing together these
different kinds of materials and
thinking about the different forces that
have been pushing
back against one another and building on
one another you see these five
primary things happening you see real
people encountering challenges with how
platforms work and trying to figure out
ways around them and i can guarantee you
that any platform
under the sun you can see this happening
right this minute
somebody is encountering some limits of
the way the technology has been
developed and is trying to figure out a
way around it and that's where a lot of
innovation happens
so one really crucial piece of this is
the importance of
of user agency and of real people
thinking through problems and problem
solving and their role in shaping the
platforms we take for granted
uh there's also stories of businesses
seeking to grow of twitter saying oh
maybe it's not going to be
cool to be so casual and playful maybe
we need some metrics maybe we need to
pitch ourselves as news maybe we need to
make analytics on every tweet available
and put that little box that you saw in
that last
screen that gene showed you showing
people you know hey if you want to
promote it
here's how you do it i.e if you want to
give us some money
we'll up your numbers even further right
so
you get this shift as the business tries
to grow and become more serious
moving from that sort of more social
impulse more social motivation
for the site and for its users to
becoming a site for news and for
self-promotion and we haven't talked a
lot about how
dependent upon twitter journalists are
but that's a really important piece of
this
story also is that twitter becomes the
place where journalists hang out with
one another and often turn to
for their own information you have this
movement we've talked about in a number
of ways from these interpersonal
logics to these media industry logics
that are about capturing attention
capturing eyeballs selling
advertisements
and you also see a movement from
third-party innovation to centralized
control so
the uh the fact that hashtags used to be
supported by third parties and are now
embedded entirely within the site
um is an example of this and we point to
others
uh so these are the
the phases one sees in the story of
twitter this might not be the exact same
story you would see
in every single platform and we would
hope that it wouldn't be
the same story you would see in every
single platform facebook has its own
very different qualities from twitter as
do
these other sites as well um and there's
many platforms we're not mentioning
in these four little icons but you can
imagine
all kinds of all kinds of platforms they
do
share these
qualities that twitter has though of
they have features
and they have stories that go across
time so if one
wants to take this platform biography
approach and apply it
to looking at these other platforms as
we hope that people will do
and i might say also that although this
is our platform biography of twitter
it's one
that spans a very particular time in its
history and it doesn't need to be the
only one
that's ever written one could easily do
one
that covers a much more recent time
period and pulls on different features
like trending topics
lists would be amazing so if one is
going to implement the platform
biography approach
in any platform this is how we
suggest going about it first is to
identify a platform of interest not too
surprisingly
second would be to find some examples of
the evidence that would meet these basic
principles
on the right and the third would be then
to identify some key features through
which that platform story could be told
and these key principles these basic
principles
uh that we want to stress and that i
hope have come through as
as gene and i have talked through the
history of twitter
is the way that the hardware and
software devices and interviews
interfaces and protocols change over
time the way that users experiences and
practices
change over time the way that business
strategies are changing over time
and the way that both media
representations and self-representations
of the platform also
evolve over time
and with that i think we're done so we
have got some live q a following for
those of you who are watching
on time and we've got some polls
that i hope you guys take time to answer
and we're standing by ready to answer
your questions
gene thank you very much
all right thanks so much
hi everybody uh thanks for sticking with
us uh i'm nancy bain
and i'm here with gene burgess uh and
we've been really enjoying your
questions you've been submitting during
the
during the thing and trying to get at
them we've got a few saved
that we thought merited a little more
lively discussion
but we're still taking questions while
we talk
we might start with maybe one of those
softballs
from kylie about feeling sad or
nostalgic for the old non-broadcasty
twitter to which i gotta say
oh my gosh yes and one of the things
that we say in the book is twitter used
to be fun
and you know now it's um well the term
doom scrolling didn't come out of
nowhere did it
ah gene you want to say anything about
that
yeah i totally totally totally agree i
mean
um i think one of the arguments that
in in the book that maybe is implicit is
that it's by no means inevitable that
just because something scales up that it
has to become
this um loud antagonistic
kind of cultural war zone um and
and or even when it's not being a
cultural war zone a place for
for um attention speaking
and um and broadcasting logics
that the interpersonal and sociable
nature of the platform didn't have to go
away and i think
um sometimes it shines through even
today even amidst everything going on in
the news right now
yeah which might lead up to
holly's question where did that go
and holly asked did you notice a renewed
embrace of the quotidian and mundane
the dreaded photos of one's meals from
the early years of twitter
on twitter in the early weeks and months
of the pandemic or has that now mainly
moved to other platforms or both
but is now overwhelmed by the more
lauded news function
i love that question because one of the
things that i kept thinking about
at the start of the pandemic was that
suddenly everybody was posting pictures
of bread and they're still posting
pictures
of bread so that quotidian i think not
only came back
but it um the fact that it had
been there all along and had clung a
clung
clung to twitter despite all the efforts
to
get rid of it um set us up to slip
fairly easily into sustaining ties in a
period
of isolation yeah we we use
we still use and instinctively reach for
these platforms even twitter to to reach
each other to connect with each other on
the basis of our
shared everyday experience and
so those moments not only gave me
a little more hope for humanity but you
know well not only a little more hope
for twitter but a little more hope for
humanity i think i should say
what else do we have here nancy well
there are some people who are asking
about do you foresee problems with zoom
or i want to be looking at multiple
platforms
um you have thoughts on on
questions about applying this to other
platforms in general
well i think we we um
touched on this a little bit at the end
of the
presentation but because
every platform is um particular
comes at a different time in history
maybe has different levels of different
degrees of openness to scrutiny
you have to kind of problem solve for
each one but
um i mean it's a shame we can't just sit
down and have a great chat with you all
because i'd love to hear your thoughts
actually on
which of these principles you think can
be generalized and which can't
but certainly we think um and and in
workshops where we've
taught this stuff we found that trying
to hone
in on particular distinctive
features that you know that make
that provide the twitterness of twitter
the youtubeness of youtube
or or um the ticktockness of tiktok
whatever it might be is a useful thing
to think with
so thinking about what is the
distinctive
um feature affordance or practice
with each of these platforms and then to
kind of do a thought experiment where
you think well where would i find
materials where would i where would i
find an archive
that might tell me about um this feature
whether it's just
it being talked about whether those
traces are set to be found on the
platform itself
um or some other place so
yeah i mean like i said i'd love to hear
from you what you think
the zoomness of zoom might be in that
sense
or what else do we have in the chat we
had discord
it's another good one i think
and yeah to answer the question about
discord yeah somebody should study it
i think that would be really good
yeah maybe you definitely
um
part of what the platform biography
offers is a bit of a way to
compare platforms as well um and
so that we're not just doing each one in
isolation part of what makes twitter
twitter is that it's not facebook and
it's not
instagram and it's it's not whatsapp and
it's not a text message and it's not a
phone call so
the ecosystem within which any of these
platforms exist
is a really important component of what
makes them
what they are so for example when
twitter
uh started explicitly saying we're not a
social network we're an information
network
they were choosing quite strategically
to distinguish themselves from facebook
uh the question did you want to say
something about that gene
no no okay i'm just looking at um
ashwin's question here about and emily
we were dependent and emily's if we
could if we could talk to the people
there's a number of questions that sort
of get out what if we could get to the
algorithms what if we could get to the
people who run it what if we had
a perfect view of of
all aspects of this what story would we
tell differently or
or how would that help you wanna you
wanna respond to that i have thoughts
but i'd love to hear yours too stitching
i have a few thoughts um one of them
that i feel like um
the company-centered story of platforms
um is probably more
frequently told and
that tends to center the designers
engineers business models as
um almost the the only actors or the
the determinants of what platforms
become and while of course
obviously um they are super important um
um i'm really concerned in all of my
work
to think about the role of
diverse user communities who don't
always agree
in in co-shaping or co
in the co-evolution of these platforms
and so actually
it's um as important to get at
the equally um non-obvious experiences
of
users over time the change in the way
that the platform's actually experienced
used practiced that's just as important
as trying to figure out what people were
thinking behind the scenes
and secondly in terms of um
you know quite rightly a lot of people
in our sort of fields at the moment are
trying to understand
what algorithms are doing there's a
sense that you could get inside the
black box
and figure out what they're doing but
again implicit argument in what we've
done here is that
you can find out a lot about what
they're doing based on what they
what effects they have on how the
platform looks and works and
is experienced by real people
nancy uh i i wanna i i love those
answers and i'm gonna i'm gonna let them
stand because i think that
this is a really important part uh i
really like this question that
uh yupa has asked about why do we leave
out the likes feature is it less
significant
and the reason uh that we don't talk
about the likes feature
is that we came to these three features
because we
we asked people to download their
archives
and go through them and find places
where they felt like the way that they
tweeted
changed and then we interviewed them
about that and it was through that
process that
those three things emerged from user
experience as being
really important and likes somehow
weren't
i think likes are crucially important um
but they didn't stand out in the same
way as
part of what makes twitter twitter
partly i guess because you can like on
every
platform so it wasn't distinctive to the
twitter per se
although it would be a nifty extension
exercise for
someone yeah it would be awesome to read
a paper about that
yeah and actually um while we were
drafting the manuscript there was that
controversy about the
star the twitter star which used to be
what you used to mark something right
used to the draft used to open with the
excel
people got so upset when the star turned
into a heart
yeah the exploding heart uh and that was
it yeah
and i mean i think in terms of applying
this approach to other platforms finding
those little moments where there's
testation about a platform change like a
little controversy analysis is a really
nifty
neat way to get at how all of these
different elements of the platform
are intersecting and affecting what it
means
anna is asking about how this compares
to the walkthrough method developed by
you
and colleagues at qut gene you want to
speak to that
briefly maybe you could tell folks what
the walkthrough method is because
perhaps some people
listening are not familiar with that and
it's another great strategy for looking
at
platforms so the app walkthrough method
is another
um set of tools to do the cultural
analysis
of apps or platforms
and i would say so that just involves
um really just slowing down the user
experience
and kind of obsessively documenting
through lots and lots of screenshots
exactly what an app looks like
as as you flow through it as a user and
using that
to try to figure out what questions to
ask about how the app
or platform works on the back end and i
would say that could be a useful tool as
part of a platform biography
so if you really wanted to figure out
what aspects of the interface
were really worth doing a history of
that that the walkthrough might be a
really useful first step
i'm thinking about deborah's question
here about sampling participants and i i
just wanted to say that uh we
uh we we sample participants based on
convenience we we
don't have a claim to uh
any kind of random sample or anything
like that and
and my hope would be my assumption would
be that if you were to speak with
uh if you were to take different kinds
of populations and do the same thing you
might find different features of twitter
and
again this is where i think the
biography metaphor
is useful because this is true of people
as well if you if you uh tell the story
of a person from
one person's one population's point of
view you're going to get a very
different story than if you tell it from
somebody else's point of view and that's
it doesn't make one or the other story
less true
they're both um valid tales of
what this platform meant in people's
lives
character limit
there are a lot of questions here so
we're just reading through them trying
to figure out where we
uh do we want to talk about spam and
and bots and and non-organic content
i i i guess what i would say about that
uh this is in response to the question
what would you say is the impact of
non-organic content spam bots in the
twitter experience and how has it
evolved
through twitter's history or in recent
times
i think the impact has been
uh to pollute to pollute and disrupt and
damage
damage the environment and i think that
it's a
result of incentives that
that we've talked about of this media
logic that drives particular kinds
of behaviors because the whole point of
these boxes to trend
is to appropriate hashtags is to
drive replies is to get retweeted is to
is to flood to flood the system
so i think it's it's a
by and large i think it's a bad
development that can be traced at least
in part to the shift in logics that we
have tried to outline here agree
i think we have time for maybe one more
and
i think i'd like to answer peter's peter
clark's question here
twitter different consumption models
from so
uh um many other platforms have multiple
consumption models i think this is a
a great one because the answer is these
days
uh not many i think twitter was
twitter is an interesting case but it
because it was kind of at the end of the
open innovation web 2.0
um ethos where you would build a a bare
bones platform
open up its various apis
to third-party developers and they would
figure out what it was for
and other applications they'd invent all
of the different
user clients meaning the apps that you
you access twitter through
but gradually twitter converged with the
other platforms
in going for a really seamless
integrated user experience
so they basically brought up those
third-party apps
and then set up their rules to make it
uh impossible for developers to develop
new ones tweak deck is kind of the last
man standing i guess
because it's something that is really
important for power users
but not all users so it's just a great
question
to allow us to talk about that um other
bit of
the platform's history in terms of its
relationship
to the rest of the social media
ecosystem and and technical ecosystem
i think we need to wrap it up so i think
we need to wrap
up and say thank you all so much for
attending
and we really appreciate we were well
gosh what if nobody asked questions but
ha ha
you showed up and we love it um we've
got a resource section that should be
somewhere on your screen or accessible
to you uh
you can access the introduction to the
book and some other
uh some other writings and things like
that some other sources
um so we're hoping that you guys all
build on this and
and we look forward to seeing some other
platform biographies in the future about
discord and
zoom and all those other platforms out
there and
last point i'll make is that yes
economists and media studies people
use platform very differently in one
case it's seen as a marketplace and in
another it's seen as a stage so
astute observation there thank you so
much everybody
and we'll see you on twitter
thank you so much everyone